THINE  FOR
SPECIAL , ONE TO VE T
ELECTIONS, AND TO
INVESTIGATE HUNTER BIDEN INTTIO
LADERING.
IDS
SENATE MIN
CO TO LOOK AALUMP WON
SOON SO GIVE UP.
THS SOON G TO HAVE E ATTOERAL, E
.
DO YOU KNOW IF JOE BIDEN IS NG ?
>>ter: WE DON'T KNOW, BUT
THE PRESIDENT IS PUBLICLY MAKING
THISHE'S TALKING ABOUT
MEETINGS WITH HIS , IT'S BEING
MEDIA.
PLICATE THINGS WITH RE, WHAT PO
ITNG TO HAPPEN.LD THE PRESIDE IA
SPECCOUNLSE FOR
ALLEGED VOTER FRAUD AN
THERID
UWA BUT
WHAT JEFFY RON
WOULD DO OR IF HE WOULD TR
GET BARR TO DO IT  H
A WEEK FROM TODAY. HAVE HEARE P
SPECULATED WHE H
APPOINT A SPECIAL COUNSEL, BUT
GENEMUO ITT LIKE
LET US HAVE ROBERT F URSE,
MUELLER AS THE SPECIAL COUNS.
AND APPOINE SPECIAL ION,WOULD T
COUNSELS
JAKE, THOSE ARE TIONS WE
N'TO, AND
IDENT WOD
MEETING TODAY, THE AN, PRESEN
FIRST ONE IN A LONG AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE CABINET DID
SHOW UP.
>> ReporEAMUCH OHEADS-UP TY GOTT
THIS CABINET MEETING WAS ENAS B
PRESIDENT LIKES THE
ME BUT THEY DID NOT HAO INODAY.
WE LATER LEARNED FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE DID
NOT SHOW UP, INCLUDING ANYONE
FROM THEUS
ANYONE FROM THANYONE
FROM THE STATE DEPARTMENT OR
ANYONE FROCIA. OF THEM WERERE,
TYPICALL CABET
N'T MAKE IT, IF THEY'R
TRAVELING OR MAYBE THEY'RE
CORONAVIRUS, THEY WOND A MPEO E
BUT THERE WERE NPUTY        EAN
THIS MEETING THOUGH
THERE'S ONLY FS TO GO SO
IT'S NOT CART THEY WOULD
ACCOMPLISH, BUT NOBODY GOT BACK
TO US ABOUT WHY THEY WEREN'T  J.
HUNTER BIDEN IS BEING
ATTORNEY FOR MONEYG. HAV
WOD Y HAVE F COU HANDL
FAIRLY, BUT ALSO THINTIAL LI BIN
CK DECIDE WHAT
TO DO.
>> WELL, I THINK THAT,VEHE LAW,
IT DOES MAKE.IT MIGHT BE  T THE
ON.BUT I WANT TO BE VERY CLE TIU
SPECIAL COUNSELS
INVESTIGATE POLITICAL OPPONENTSM
.
THESE ARE NOT THLD BE Y TAXPAYE
IF WRONGLOOK INTO ITON'T WANT AF
KE LAW, AND
WE DYBODY ABUS
HOWEVER, WE DON'T ALSOAN THAN I
INVESTIGATE YOURPPONENTS. NOT GH
PUOT GOOD FOR US AS
>>NLY HOOUGOING PRESIDENT TRUMPO
USE THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.N, THERO
INVESTIGATE THE 20LECTION
THERE HAVE ALREADY BEEN AT LEA
THREE RECOUNTS, LOTSF
INVESTIGATIONS, LOTS OF COURT GE
THEMERE HAS BEEN NO EVIDENCE O
WHAT IS THERTO INVESTITESPECIALD
ANR PE
AND DEMOCRATS ANNONPARTISAN
PEOPLE?ND ALSTHE RTMENT WHICH T
APPOINT THE SAL LOOK  FROM BIRN
Y ACTUALLY DID LOOK INTO
SOME OF E IC CLAIMTHPRESIDENT A.
HE SAID THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY ALSO LOOKED
INY DID NOT FIND EVIDENCE OF THA
REPUBLICANS.YO HROM AND OTHER
SO IT'T LD
HAT.
BUT WHS IS THAT THE
D ABOUT PEOPLE THAT  SPECIAL CO
LL APPOINTEEO
COULD POSITTA T
SO WHETHER OR NOT ITESTION IS S.
TR WEEKS LEFT IN
HE'S MADE IT C HS TH
HE W B
LEAVES AND I'M TRECENT
DAYS.
MITCHLL
DEN WON
REPUBLICAN, TO ACKNOWLEDGENGE JN
JOE BIDEN WON IN THE EOR LLEGE.
T JOE BIDEN IS GOING OK.
WI?BE NEDENT-ELECT
>> KEVIN McCARTHCOMPLETELY
IGNORING THE QUESTION, TELIICANT
COLLEAGUES, HOUSE REPUBLICANS,
GOING TO ACKNOWLEDGE REALITY UNN
ELEGE TOE THEIR
DEAND WAITING
BUT AT THIS POINT THERE IS A L
OFOR DO.
SAME WAY ID THERE WAS ANONEL 20
WAS  ELECTION HELDICH JOE BIDEN
WO MOVE ON.
THERE ARE A LOOF THINGS THAT
PEOPLE NEED TO
PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT VIRUD
ABOUT W OMY IS GOING,
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT MAKING
SURE THEY PUT FOOD OTH
THIS IS THE  I THINK
AT ELECTIONS HAV
UEES
REALL
REMARKLEH ESTRUMP HAS NOT BEEN
LI YOU.HE'S DONE A COUPLE IVIRI
JOE BIDEN HIDING IN S HE'S REAL.
WHAT DO YOU  OF IT A
>> Reporter: IT'CREDIBLY
RER FROM THEY HE HAS BEEN
ACTING OVER THE LAST SEVERALS,
CABINET MEETING TODAY LY
IDL BEE THAT IS
SOMETHING TYPICALLY THE
REPORTERS TO COMIN. THINK OF ON
ETING THAT HAPPENED LAST YEA
WHERE REPORTS
INTO THE ROOM.
ROUGHT US IN IN MAEN
THEY HAD ONE.
NT WHERE HE JUSTSENSYOG
REPORTERS.
IT ALSO SEEMS TO BE FILTERING
INTO AND WHAHE TYPICALLY DOES O
HOLIDAYS.
REMEMBER O HCANCELED A T MARO?
RIGHT NOW THERE IS INTERNA.
CONFUSION AS TETHER HE'S
GOING AT ALL OVER CHRISTMAS
BREAK.
STAFFERS HAVE SAID THEY DON'T N
THAT IS OFTEN THE OPPORTUNITY PS
GOLFINE WALKS AROUND AND
MPH GUESN THE
ACU'RE JUST NOT SEEING THEHIS F
DONALD TRUMP, AND I THINFROM
THAT HAS TO DO WITH
THATBEEN ENTIRELY CO